The general good experience in,
they always have those kinds of things.
There's all sorts of different classes
that you like
is awesome.
I've done one of those high intensity
interval training things at a yoga place
to do.
You do some yoga and some like really
light weights,
but all these crazy little exercises.
That's fun too.
We got a good dancer pose.
Got a dancer pose.
Yeah.
Wait,
let me see.
He's A.
Oh,
you try to do that.
Don't hurt yourself.
Yes.
Oh,
that is that what it's called?
Standing Bow.
Good things called standing bow and
there's this one.
Keep it going.
Are you going?
No one can see you.
You're supposed to grab both legs,
but that's okay.
Grab that other leg,
but she got it.
Nope.
Come on son.
Here he goes.
Nice.
And the headphones on.
Take it to the new level.
It's like a NASA mission called again,
a cry for help.
I call it the crab.
When you say you do yoga,
like how often do you do it?
When I would go,
I would go to hot yoga.
You go a couple times a week are now.
I just kind of do it in my backyard to
stretch out after a long flight or
something.
That's good.
Anything you had the tank like that's a
time to think about life,
to think through it.
Think through a mission that you're
working on.
Some family issue.
It's like quiet your.
It's about you.
For me,
Yoga,
it's like giving yourself a massage.
It's more gratifying than going to
can get real weights and stuff.
I like to stretch out before sets.
You ever do that?
Do stretches before we go do this.
It feels real good that like there's
something about that that's very
relaxing.
Puts you in a good.
I think you carry around when you're
tight,
you carry around a lot of tension that
you don't necessarily want.
Pigeon pose.
That's where all the tension is.
That's the one
where your.
Where your leg comes under your.
I want to ask Joe,
what the fuck is he doing?
Oh Wow.
Jeff,
that.
Oh,
I've seen this one.
Yeah,
I've seen that one.
That's called a hip opener.
Good hips,
Bro.
That looks so sad.
One like if you go to hot yoga and
people will do that pose and start
crying because there's so much emotion
and anxiety release from the hitch,
that's not real.
You're just crying because someone told
you you should cry.
You want to be a part of the group cry
nonsense.
They always want to say that this is
opening up your colon.
You don't have any fucking.
There's no diagrams.
You don't know where the colon is like,
you better stop.
I Dunno when I fight,
it's like I'm fighting and yeah,
it's a poor shield in a sense,
you know?
And uh,
sometimes if it hurts enough,
like when I got my ribs cracked,
I felt that right.
I can went through and I like disrupted
my for shield and so sometimes that's
something we'll go through,
like a good solid or shield four.
Shields will activate your attitude.
Your mindset is like you're fighting,
you're,
you're ready to accept all sorts of
things.
Yeah.
Like I could die
or even harder.
I could kill someone.
You think it'd be harder to kill someone
than to die and so her on you?
Yeah.
Because then you think about their loved
ones,
so thinking about all the people that
loved you,
we fight.
Think about all the people that love
you.
Right?
And so when we fight,
I didn't,
I didn't break any rules,
but I killed you.
Right?
Think about all your loved ones.
Everybody that loves you that's attached
to you.
Think about that.
All that pain
because of what I did.
The you right.
Even though I didn't break any rules,
have you ever been in a promotion where
someone died?
But that's heavy,
right?
I think probably why a lot of fighters I
have noticed like there's,
there's,
I don't think the majority of fighters a
look at what they do with the gravity
that,
that it deserves.
You know,
like you could kill somebody,
like you need to think about that and be
okay with that.
Not Okay,
but just understand like,
all right,
that could happen and I'm going to be
calm,
consciously knowing this and choosing to
go forward.
They just think,
oh,
I'm going to fight.
It'll be fun.
It'll know whatever.
Or it'll be harder.
I'm gonna like whatever.
They don't think about these things.
Is this something that you thought about
when you were young?
Yeah.
Before I really got into it.
So you,
this is something you've been
contemplating even before you started
fighting,
you were aware of all the possibilities?
Yeah,
I.
Okay.
All right.
I'll say it.
So I was um,
it was uh,
about 28 I think and I don't think I had
my pro boxing debut yet and I took some
mushrooms and I was thinking somewhere
along the trip I started thinking about
fighting and I started thinking about
like what could happen to me and I think
it's thinking about the death of me.
And then I started thinking about what
could happen with my opponent,
like what's worse than that?
And I thought about I could see somebody
I fight and I saw all the,
like,
like lines of gold thread attached into
them,
like a from their loved ones.
And then all the lines got snipped when
they died.
Yeah.
I saw this on this mushroom trip and I
was just like,
fuck.
And so then when I decided to fight,
there's more intense,
you know,
and more commitment and more resolve.
That's heavy.
Yeah.
But that is what it is.
Right?
And that's where I think real,
there's more power.
This idea of a enforced equality,
right?
Ensuring that there is such a high
emphasis played or placed on equality,
equality,
that you have the equal amount of men,
the equal amount of women and the
opportunities are absolutely available
as much to women as they are to men.
This is enforced that this creates an
environment where there's less
resistance.
Now in an environment where there's less
resistance,
perhaps women don't feel as compelled to
say,
I'll show you that.
That is what seems to happen.
This is the key.
Look,
here's an example.
So there are fewer women mathematicians
in the,
in the higher echelons.
Okay?
But here's something interesting about
mathematical ability.
First of all,
it's very rare.
So that's the first thing to keep in
mind.
Now it looks like if you look in junior
high that give mathematically gifted men
and males and females are approximately
as common.
Now there's a little bit of debate about
that because there is some evidence that
maybe at the very upper extremes there's
a male advantage just like there's a
male disadvantage at the low end because
the mail distribution for intelligence
might be flatter and so that's the
greater male variability hypothesis.
There's been papers putting that forward
that had been retracted as a consequence
of pressure from politically correct
people.
Even though greater male variability is
actually quite common in the animal
kingdom for a variety of reasons.
Men are more expendable,
that males are more expendable in some
ways,
or you could say that males are more
likely to produce to pursue high risk,
high return strategies.
You can look at it either way and it's
certainly possible.
In any case,
the men,
the males in junior high who happened to
be mathematically gifted,
are less likely to also be verbally
gifted.
Whereas that doesn't seem to be the case
for the females.
And so if you're a male math nerd,
then math is pretty logical pathway for
you because you don't have as many other
options.
Whereas if you're female math nerd,
you have other options because you're,
you're less likely,
you're more likely to also be verbally
gifted,
and so that's enough to at least in
principle account for some of the reason
why there are fewer women mathematicians
than men.
Mathematicians.
They have other options.
They have other options and there's lots
of complex.
There's lots of complex reasons like
this,
and so we have this reflects of idea and
this is very much the case because this
is like the core idea among the feminist
neo Marxist types is that if there's
differences in outcome,
that's that's proof of prejudice and
that support for the idea of the
patriarchal tyranny and that's like the
core axiom of the radical left is the
patriarchal tyranny as far as I'm
concerned.
That's God for them to patriarchal
tyranny.
It's like,
well,
if it turns out that many of these
differences in outcome between men and
women aren't a consequence of the
patriarchal tyranny,
in fact,
even get bigger.
When you reduce the tear radical aspect
of the patriarch and even the
patriarchal aspect to it,
then it makes that theory not only wrong
but opposite of the truth,
which is the worst kind of wrong and so
you know,
if men are more likely to produce per
pursue careers in the stem fields,
which seems to be the case under
conditions of optimal freedom for men
and women,
then that's going to drive income
disparities because the stem fields pay
more and they pay more.
Partly because they're scalable,
like it's really hard to scale care for
people.
You know,
like if you work in a daycare,
you're going to care for three infants.
You're not going to care for 50 because
you can't.
It's not scalable.
But if you're like a software designer,
it's infinitely scalable.
And so there's,
there's a much wider range of possible
of possibility for generating much
larger,
much larger income pools and much larger
pools of wealth.
You know,
and men are also more likely to work
longer hours.
And if you work 10 percent longer hours,
you make 40 percent more money.
There's a nonlinear return on.
That's good thing for everybody who's
listening to know if you have a job,
you want to be the guy or the woman
who's working that extra 10 percent
because the return on that is nonlinear,
so that's a really useful thing to know
and I don't know how it got
distinguished,
were proud boys became this evil group
of people and an Antifa is the good
group of people.
Now I understand that.
Proud boy,
proud boys were infiltrated by white
nationalist,
Nazi,
White Supremacist,
whatever it is,
but those were constantly being
disavowed by Gavin.
Gavin never wanted any of that happen,
but is there a way.
How do you get in though?
Here's the question because this is my.
You saw my last comedy special
[inaudible].
This is my criticism of a vegans is not
that there's anything wrong with being a
Vegan is that when you have a group
where anybody can join,
you're going to get a certain amount of
fucking idiots,
right?
If you have a million people for sure
you have 100,000 fucking idiot.
He has no getting around that.
Yeah,
so if you have a group where anybody can
join and you have a million people in
that group,
you're going to have 100,000 fucking
fucking idiots.
Those people are going to define your
group.
The worst behavior in the group is where
people are going to call too as an
example.
That's it.
I think this is also a symptom of the
social media era today,
especially with twitter because you
can't express yourself and explain
things in 140 or 280 characters.
It just takes too much time so they can
say,
oh,
proud boys,
racist scumbag Nazi Gavin,
and they'll always a racist scumbag
Nazi.
Then all of a sudden that's the
narrative and everybody keeps pushing
it.
Videos of people punching little skinny
people.
Oh,
look at these people.
They beat up the Antifa,
these fucking assholes,
and Gavin's an asshole.
Yeah,
that's.
That's what it comes down to.
I've seen it presented a.
well.
You ask how it starts and how it grows
and how you become a member by buying a
fucking shirt.
That's by buying a Perry Ellis shirt and
opening a chapter two.
There are chapters worldwide,
you see it.
It's like,
here's the the proud boys,
here's the problem.
He's England proud boys,
fucking Japan,
like it's everywhere and it never was
supposed to get to that point and
regardless of how these people act,
it now reflects on Gavin even though he
wanted to hang out in a bar with a few
people do is public speaking without
being hassled and that's it.
And I see the way the media manipulates
things.
I've been party to it myself and I've
seen Gavin presented in photos where you
look and go,
holy fuck.
It's Hitler.
Like,
like they get them.
There's one picture,
Gavin,
that I was petrified by.
He's got his arms folded,
he's got a scowl on his face,
that hair,
you know,
the short on the side,
long on the top and he's looking like
he's angry and I'm like that.
That's not the guy that him and his wife
who's American Indian by the way.
His wife is American Indian.
He's got beautiful kids that come over
my house and use the pool and we hang
out and barbecue.
I'm like,
that's not that guy.
No one knows that guy from the paper.
They're getting this impression.
He's a really nice guy.
He's.
He's a generous.
Just a really cool guy to hang out with
and what you see them do in the media is
just crazy.
Especially when you know he didn't
invent some Goddamn Nazi group.
He was just trying to have a little
outrageous fun and it ran from him.
It got away from them.